The stories that,
that we tell and that we live in are
fundamentally ways that we deal with the
complexity of the world.
And the fundamental problem with
the world as far as I can tell,
is that not only is it complex
beyond your comprehension,
but the complexity shifts
in unpredictable ways.
So that's the Darwinian
conundrum actually.
That's why Darwinism seems to be a
practical necessity with regards to the
continuation of life,
because because of the
complexity changes unpredictably,
you can't necessarily tell what's
going to work in the future.
And so the Darwinian process solves
that by generating quasi random
variations and letting,
whichever one by happenstance happens
to work in that environment survive now.
And it's not random precisely because
the underlying structure is conserved.
It's very rare that a child would be
born with an extra arm or something like
that.
And like the skeletal structure that you
inhabit is shared by animals going way,
way back in evolutionary history.
There's a lot of conservation
and in the evolutionary process,
but so there's variation
within conservation,
like music.
It's a good,
it's a good way of thinking about it.
And so
the,
the stories that we tell have
exactly the same structure.
They,
they have this,
his core element with variations.